the jurogan experience he's the
i've told this story before but i'll
tell you he's the reason why this table
is this wide
oh you're just nervous this table was
going to be i was going to make it more
narrow i even had a smaller table that
we were working with as a guide
yeah and then we were still doing the
shows back in l.a we're setting up this
studio
i did an interview with tyson and he was
so amped up for this roy jones fight
that i got nervous
i'm like i like that extra six inches
that's hilarious
space between us because he was so
ramped up oh man when he left jamie goes
that's a totally different person yeah
because he went from being
mike tyson pot grower right not working
out at all
to get ready to go to combat again
getting ready to [ __ ] throw hands
yeah yeah that's so amped up and you
we've all watched the video where he
calls that photographer out and he's
like how [ __ ] you give up
eat your ass [ __ ] you [ __ ] i'll make
you love me yeah i watch that i'm like
ah
he said i'll [ __ ] you until you love me
wow where does that come from an
inner demon that's letting a dude know
he's gonna be [ __ ] him for a long
time
yeah but it's a weird jump because he's
not actually gonna [ __ ] the guy he's
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of him he might
he might if he decides to that's his
call that's what
that's what it is yeah that's what it is
when he's yelling at you he's letting
you know
if i decide to yeah you're not i'll i'll
[ __ ] you until you
love me that is like one of the deepest
darkest things a person's ever said to
somebody
that haunts me at night terrifying but
plus
back then i mean he was in his pride oh
yeah that was
that was you know post prison i think
that was the linux lewis fight
i believe that was the press conference
for the lennox lewis fight so that
wasn't
exactly prime but we didn't know that
yet he was
kind of still in the area like he had
already lost to buster douglas right
he might have already lost to evander
holyfield i think he did
i don't know it's just amazing that
there's people on this planet who are
like
oh i'll fight that guy they're looking
at video footage of this
[ __ ] killer and they're like yeah
i'll take them there's a lot of killers
out there
i know they always want to be the man
who beats the man
that's what it is that gives me hope i
know we call it toxic masculinity or
whatever the hell evil men but it
it's amazing that somebody would want to
go toe-to-toe with this
[ __ ] what is what is this about this
is a different i know it is
i'll eat your children oh this is a
different one yeah play this
play this
uh jamie the covet has really hurt yeah
i think it's it's
been slacking since yeah i don't know
something's wrong by the way quite a hog
on jmo i saw it in the sweatpants yeah
quite a piece you got there there you go
man
he's not denied it either he's smiling
he's all red now look oh my god
you look like the walls no get it out
there get it out tell them
they come up with with a hog in place
that's like
legitimate legitimate like good to go
everyone universally accepted the way
fake boobs are accepted yeah cause fake
boobs are
basically normal no one says listen
you've got a great personality but this
is [ __ ]
girls in high school are doing that [ __ ]
oh yeah oh yeah
oh is that legal how was that well you
know you hit 18 or whatever
oh god but yeah i feel like it should be
21 before you do something like that
yeah but man would i kill for a huge
tongue how big would you want
well you're you're there's rumors about
your uh your
[ __ ] and balls there but uh i used to
have a bit about big dick pills
yeah if there was big dick pills it
would take about 30 seconds for the
first guy diving to overdose
no one's gonna take just one if a pill
makes your dick bigger
we'd be thinking like how many do i take
before i get a stroke give me one less
and let's [ __ ] do this it would
change the shape of vaginas because
there would be no regular dicks anymore
then there we go here we go with mike
tyson
who's standing by with jim gray jim yeah
okay thank you steve mike was that your
shortest fight ever
i've been witness there's only one god
and muhammad blessings and peace be upon
him is the prophet
i dedicate this fight to my brother
daryl brown who died
i'll be there to see you i love you with
all my heart
all praise be to my children i love you
oh god
oh man what is this your shortest fight
ever
in any time amateur professional jim
gray hanging in there yeah
um i don't know man
yeah yeah linux lewis linux i'm coming
for you
mike is it frustrating to train like you
did and then have this in seven or eight
seconds
i only trained probably two weeks or
three weeks for this fight
i had to bury my best friend and i
dedicated this fight i wasn't going to
fight i dedicated this fight to him
i was going to rip his heart out i'm the
best ever i'm the most brutal and
vicious and most ruthless champion has
ever been there's no one can stop me
lynx is a conqueror no i'm alexander
he's no alexander i'm the best
ever there's never been anybody i'm sony
listen i'm jack dempsey there's no one
like me i'm from their club
there's no one that can match me my
style is impetuous
my defense is impregnable and i'm just
ferocious i want your heart i want to
eat his children
praise be to allah
that's the craziest post-fight speech
of all time there is no second place
no he's got great writers
and even the ways my style is impetuous
my defense is impregnable
yeah it was just bam i am sonny liston
i'm jack dempsey
i'm from their cloth he got to there
from the easiest question that was a yes
or no
is this the shortest fight all he did
was yep or nah
and he just went all the way to left
field that was amazing
yeah that was heavy that was heavy i
would i mean could you be in his
entourage because he seems like a guy
who could just flip on a dime and you
just like hey you want the funyuns i
[ __ ] kill you you're like oh [ __ ] i'm
sorry
we've been best friends for 30 years
yeah i don't know if he would be like
that
uh when i've met him he's been very nice
and very friendly to everybody but
i think when you're a dude that's that
[ __ ] driven
and that maniacal when you're at your
best i mean he was you got to realize
like throughout his life
all of his great success came from his
ability
to be ferocious all of it right i mean
the whole success of his fighting career
came from his skill
his technique and his ability in the the
heat of the moment to be ferocious yeah
he's just geared up for that
you know that's there it is right this
is this is the other one though
yeah oh god that guy must be trembling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you go back to the green room
with that guy you uh
you go uh you're right mike yeah
good point well said uh well said i
think you did everything perfect
let's get out of here if i was uh that
if i was that good ass white boy i had
been running out the fire exits
that guy still to this day probably if
he's still alive probably wakes up in
the middle and like jesus
yeah like it's thinking of mike tyson
over his bed oh
i love you i love you punching him in
the face holy [ __ ]
but again like the in the context of a
regular life
that is uh outrageous behavior that you
would never expect from anybody
but in the context of a life where
you're rewarded
for being the most ferocious and
you're ruthlessly successful at doing
that
like that is normal this is like it you
like
you look at his fights the the stoppage
of trevor berbick to win the title you
look at his
destruction of tyrell biggs and marbus
frazier and you go through his career
and
of course he's got that in him that's
how he can turn it on but that feels
like more
there's more there that's why he's one
of the greatest i agree i never lace up
the gloves
but it seems like there was some real
trauma like something we don't know
about
100 yeah he talked about that trauma but
that trauma
is also what motivated me to be so great
right
see the thing about a guy like him is
like you you can't
get there any other way he was not it
wasn't that it was just
skillful and just competitive and just
unbelievably technically proficient in
the art of smashing people with your
fists
yeah he also had extra gear yeah yeah
other people didn't have
he was you know and he was even
hypnotized when he was a young boy
really yeah customato uh he was telling
me the whole story of it on the podcast
that customato took him
when he was a young boy you got to
realize he's like 13 years old he gets
adopted by one of the greatest
minds in the history of boxing right
customato was uh
he was a hypnotist he was he he really
understood psychology like deeply and he
was one of the great boxing trainers
trade he trained floyd patterson jose
torres like
world champions he's in the game forever
yeah and he
was always looking for that one great
fighter and he found it in this 13 year
old kid he knew right away
because his 13 year old kid was 190
pounds
13. yeah 190 jacked at 13.
and just had incredible natural ability
and
drive yeah was getting praised for doing
something finally
whereas all of his life right [ __ ] on
and dismissed and locked in jail and all
this different stuff
now all of a sudden he's getting praised
for it and then he's getting hypnotized
he's getting hypnotized by this guy
who's telling him you don't exist
only the task exists don't fill your
mind with thoughts of yourself
and good or bad or i'm a bad person i'm
a good brother you don't exist
you just you are the task and you move
forward and you attack
yeah jesus when he was saying that you
don't exist
like think of that just the task exists
so he's got him so focused
on on going out there and attacking that
person
the other person has all these doubts
and fears and this and that and all this
[ __ ] in their mind but he's trained to
think like a locomotion just to train
yeah just coming at you you're not gonna
stop him
he's just gonna figure he's not he's not
filled with self-doubt
he's filled with confidence he's filled
with knowing at the end of him smash you
in the face you're gonna be lying on
your back
and he's gonna get that amazing good
feeling that he gets every time he does
this
right so every time he smashes people he
gets this incredible feeling
so he's dedicated just like we were
talking about lazy comics that lazy
comics can become
like actually disciplined when they want
to get their act together to do stand-up
a fighter is so motivated by that great
feeling of winning of winning that you
just become the more
you feel it the more you want it and the
more discipline you get and the more you
drive
towards it and that was him i know plus
then you had that guy with all that
hypnotic [ __ ]
and then fame and then money i mean
that's a bad gumbo
it's a bad gumbo and look look what
happened well he's okay now
he came out he came out on the other
side uh an interesting person
yeah he did that's true a lot of people
come out of it particularly before the
fight
um you know like before he had signed on
to the fight the first time i met him
and talked to him
i met him before the ufc but the first
time i talked to him on the podcast he
was a
interesting guy he's like a very
thoughtful person he thinks a lot about
things
but daddy's got that switch and he
turned that switch on before the roy
jones fight
aha as you can tell which i think he won
yeah if it was a decision yeah for sure
but there was no decisions you know i
was trying to see if anybody knew who
mike was yelling at the crowd there
oh so i googled and look who was uh in
the crowd
oh [ __ ] live he was doing it for the
tonight show with jay leno he's like a
whole week oh my god
good eye jammer like talking to tons of
people
look how skinny david is what a gig it's
a young young dave
you got to bring this up when you see
him tonight this is amazing i don't
think there's a part where he's talking
to mike here at least but
probably for safety he may or may not
have been the guy who's [ __ ] yell on
that no no he's not a white boy
oh okay okay okay okay and dave would
never yell out us
now no no no i know i was just there's
joking he was yelling at jim brewer
that's amazing that's amazing it's a lot
of people are listening they're like who
you're talking about
right right a skinny young very bold
dave chappelle
and they're playing rock paper scissors
and just he just jacked lennox lewis
rock paper scissors remember you were a
young comic you take these weird gigs
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that is hilarious wow you forget the
body of work people have just done so
much in showbiz
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience